attention deuxième boîte c'est parti
vous jouez lycée laquelle lui c'est quoi
la fête foraine aussi la bible non mais
oh ça va on se calme sans plus il a dit
ça m'arrange pas c'est celle qui est en
tout cas l'impression de vendre des
chaussures
[Rires]
alors on m'avait demandé donc la petite
camargue est 142e bars sont là bas avant
et c'est que du 43 et demi séparant les
salaires
jean tarek est excédé changeant tard je
suis excédé là est ce que tu peux
regarder si anna camarguaise en 42 fort
le monsieur s'il te plaît en ville oui
en buts ennemie pas du biel qui ne va
pas du tout il est serré oui il est
serré la maison de longwy ça ne m'a pas
dedans alors messieurs mais quoi
patrick roy